I watched so many old PT privates I
loved him back in the days
Loki missed the old PewDiePie when he
used to be more often with cry and
cinnamon toast King to be honest the old
PewDiePie is better than the current I
missed the old Peter mine I miss the old
my old beauty pie I miss the old Paree
pie spent all day watching old PewDiePie
it was brilliant I screamed I miss all
God let's talk about that
[Music]
now listen I've been doing YouTube for
five five or six years and obviously
I've undergone a massive change from my
first video to my last I am very happy
where I am right now but it still seems
that many people are stuck in the old
days and I get that that's where
probably when a lot of people found my
videos and the first time you experience
something is always gonna be the best am
i right but I thought we're gonna react
to some old videos and react to some new
videos and then we can kind of face the
facts and see it see what it's like
maybe I'm just crazy let's start with
happy wheels I get a lot of comments
about happy wheels being like the good
old days I did at least 65 happy wheels
episodes on the span of 11 months I
would literally record 10 minutes uncut
no face cam I haven't even selected a
level yet I'm doing the outro as I am
trying to find a level that was actually
funny like I'm checking that I'm
recording before it even starting I
don't know I get why people enjoy it and
I still you can still see me in there
but it's so bad it shows how gay you are
like exposing myself here I don't know I
don't really don't like that I feel like
that was I still make kind of stupid
jokes that I shouldn't make but I feel
like back then I didn't understand I was
so immature and I just thought things
were funny just because they were
offensive so I would say a lot of stupid
[ __ ] I'm not proud of it
really not but I'm also glad that I've
grown past it like this is 23 parts
later and I'm still making the same joke
about the boy it's just the same stuff
over and over
also these videos I literally just
recorded myself like 15 minutes
I probably records now four or even five
times more than that just so I can get
entertaining material and just show the
best stuff moving on to amnesia the show
that everyone associates they could all
PewDiePie with I love this intro again I
get nostalgic just seeing this intro as
well this is before a binding of issac
was popular as well as a new one new
where I stole that graphic art from
house golden rose my name's I look like
such a little [ __ ] behind this I mean I
put it in the [ __ ] all right
Israel my house it's funny because I get
a lot of comments of people saying back
in the day he was so much more natural
and didn't force that humor but
literally I was trying so [ __ ] hard
to make jokes while playing this game
like there's literally a part that I
accidentally kept in I'd get frustrated
because I didn't think the video was
entertaining so I say god dammit I'm not
funny enough
[ __ ] I don't feel like I'm funny today
we also have this this is a video I
uploaded by mistake
it's got 300,000 views back of the day I
literally did everything last minute
like I would make the video finish the
video upload the video and it was such a
stressful process to do that here I
wasn't home when I published this video
because me and my remember me and my son
went to the cinema and I accidentally
uploaded my face cam instead of the
actual video and published it so it's
literally 11 minutes of me just doing
face cam I wonder what would happen if I
did that today look at me look at him
nuts - oh I guess I guess some habits
never changed yeah damn I love how this
is still up now
amnesia was my baby amnesia was the the
series that really elevated my channel
here's one episode from the playthrough
that's good
I wanted to go back of me trying to
solve a puzzle
I can Jam you all day
that's what she said joke that's
hilarious I'm literally stuck on this
one puzzle for the entire episode here's
me using [ __ ] in the title again I
was very childish back then I really
should go through and like censor a lot
of these videos this was kind of
frustrating to watch he kept going back
and forth in the sewer area instead of
going back ya know that's literally it
my playthrough is were actually horrible
man I was so cute back then I get it now
I get it I did look cuter back then and
to be fair I was more scared back then
first time I ever experienced it's
obviously the worst time you know I
still get scared and that's why mainly I
don't play horror games anymore because
people expect like an epic reaction of
me every time and unless there's actual
jump scares in the game I don't really
get that scared and I still get
terrified while playing video games
Sophie's curse this last video I planted
it it did amazing and everyone loved it
and so did I it still is very fun for me
to get scared of games just not every
single day
also back it's also interesting because
back then it was so hard to find games
to play you can tell how YouTube has
shaped gaming industry this is a game
called The Lost Souls it was one of
maybe I could probably count the amount
of horror games before Slenderman on my
fingers like there were so few games to
play that made it for YouTube videos and
this was this was one that was really
good now there's probably hundreds or
thousands of games like this developers
have benefited from from my channel but
I think I benefited as well you know
it's a mutual thing I used to like all
my videos and good old Friday sweetiepie
recorded on a webcam not that the
quality matters I've been criticized a
lot for having bad quality but I always
thought people don't care about quality
they just want good and entertaining
videos that always comes first but to be
fair this is 13 minutes of me uncut just
answering questions
adjusting my webcast I was probably
better at being more engaging with my
audience
but to be fair my audience was a lot
smaller back then I feel like it's been
a struggle for me to adjust to from
being so small to so big and still have
a close relationship with the audience
because that's why I love about YouTube
that's why I always read the comments
and always interact with you bros it's
because that's something I love doing
if you bros didn't exist i wouldn't be
making videos honestly I really really
feel like I've gotten that connection
back we're doing these fine creation
videos together we're ain't director
your bros creations and I love that
answer
listening to voicemails a reviewing fan
art all that kind of stuff is so cool I
love that interaction between us I feel
like for the first time in a long time
that connection is back and that's
really really important to me and
instead of like milking one game into
one video I do three games in one video
because I want it to be the best video
it can be I want it to be as
entertaining as possible when really I
could probably just keep these three
separate videos keep them up
get get that money but I honestly
believe it or not
I care more about that the video is
entertaining that always always comes
first and these type of videos like keep
talking no one explodes they got so much
editing so much work into them just to
make it as funny as possible
entertaining as possible hours upon
hours of work to get that done I think
people forget that and these videos are
hilarious thanks to it I'm sure if they
were uncut a lot of people would love it
the same way and enjoyed the same way
but not as many people would be able to
watch that long of a video that's just
the case to me the improvement is clear
to me I've grown so much as an
entertainer as a comedian but also as a
person I feel like back then I was very
childish and very confused I didn't know
what I was doing but I know I enjoyed it
and it really is thanks to you bros I
always read the comments I always listen
to feedback and criticism and I feel
like that's an important part criticism
has really helped me grow
and I'm very happy about that and more
than anything I am very proud of Who I
am today and I'm also excited to keep
improving for the future old-new I feel
like it doesn't matter I'm gonna keep
making videos that I love to make and
that hopefully you bros love to watch
and really thank you bros so much for
watching me and supporting me throughout
the years even though maybe things are
different even though maybe some changes
you don't love and if you still support
me throughout that I really really
appreciate it I had to make a decision
throughout the years where I said I want
to make the videos I want to make not
only the ones my fans want to watch
because then I'm not gonna be true to
myself and what I do and eventually I'm
just gonna hate myself and what I do but
yeah that's it old versus new either way
thank you and if there's one thing that
will never change
it's the brofist thank you both for
supporting me throughout the years
do you actually brofist on the outro do
you want to do that just for good old
times sake alright here we go you ready
brofist
you